first I think the idea of the Global
Agenda councils an app is an absolutely
excellent idea and I want to commend the
world economic forum for it particularly
in this fast-changing world I belong to
the institutional governance Agenda
Council and some of the areas that we
focused on today where we Ares that I
feel are particularly important in this
changing world first I think we
recognize that the world is much more
interdependent than it used to be so
while we focused on discussing issues
around the crisis particularly with
respect to Europe recognize the problem
that Europe faces its physical it it
also affects the banks but most
importantly there is a growth and
competitiveness issue which has
dominated sets for the rest of the world
so it is important that there is a
solution that the Europeans agree on but
that there is support from across the
world for what is happening in Europe
such that we can address it as quickly
as possible because the longer it takes
the more likely will see the problems
grew and the challenges of course affect
the more vulnerable groups even much
more so it is important to recognize
that the world is interdependent to
recognize that solving the problems that
we have in any part of the world truly
impact the other parts of the world and
and having a way of making sure that in
a coordinated manner that we address
these challenges as quickly as possible
of course there are many other issues
that we took every but I did want to
focus on this very very important as we
craft the new model for governance to
focus that the world is very
interdependent thank you